my wife for whatever [ __ ] reason
absolutely loves that show that American
greed and she watches like three of
those episodes every [ __ ] night
before we go to bed night I and I always
end up falling asleep because it's the
same [ __ ] story over and over again
you know it's the same thing the guy
starts up a [ __ ] business he dressing
the part he's faking it - you make it he
gets a bunch of investors he hands out
fake spreadsheets and got these [ __ ]
innocent people just going like you know
oh yeah I saw Charlie recharge and I was
getting dirty preciate now he's like it
sounds like a good yell at me right and
then they always go you know that's
always get some really bad metaphor they
invested in an ice cream chain but this
wasn't the flavor they were looking for
when we returned glass in the ice cream
oh that [ __ ] song of American greed
okay you know who's gonna end up on
[ __ ] American great is that [ __ ] who
shot that lion everybody's talking about
this dentist that went over and
illegally poached this lion that was
friendly with people I love that [ __ ] oh
is it we're friendly with people until
what it bites somebody's [ __ ] head
off [ __ ] unreal you know what I mean
everybody's [ __ ] salient gasps the
pit bulls you shoot a [ __ ] lion
everything I'm not saying was a bad lion
I'm not saying the guy shouldn't have
done it
I think everybody's missing the [ __ ]
story here all right speaking of
American greed this guy paid 50 grand
all right that's just for the [ __ ]
that's not even for this flight to go
over there and kill this [ __ ] lion
all right no no trying to stir anything
up here but how to [ __ ] a dentist
afford to drop 50 grand to fly to Africa
to shoot a [ __ ] lion illegally just
thinking of all the how expensive the
shoes he had to buy that he had to sneak
around and they had to be some sort of
ninja
we're [ __ ] I'm gonna shoot it a
protected lion where that he had on
right guy dropped 50 grand on that and
now he's gone underground they go to his
house he's got a mansion right
and all they talking about is his
[ __ ] lion and I'm watching an episode
of American great what a [ __ ] your
phone off or I'm feeling [ __ ] how
many teeth you feeling this guy's
pulling teeth he's telling you right now
I used to work in a dental office right
all right there was some good dent it's
just like cops there's some good cops
there's some bad cops and I'm not
talking about interrogation talking
about Brian no I'm talking about [ __ ]
people pulling teeth that didn't need to
be pulled [ __ ] doing root filling
fillings on teeth that did not need to
be [ __ ] drilled into because they
bought a car beyond their own [ __ ]
needs or whatever their their their
financial responsibility all right I
think this guy should be [ __ ] taken
back there just for the simple fact just
for the simple fact that that he he went
to another country it did that what do
we got over here
does the MGM still have a lion what if
he can what if somebody from Zimbabwe
came over here what about at the MGM
lion right right as they were recording
that you're watching an MGM film they
[ __ ] please turn the air-conditioner
back on yeah the lovely need everybody
she came in this is a studio man they've
let him and had it cold I'm having a
cold he lasted [ __ ] 30 years on
television I want to do 30 years of
podcasting huh well what's good is the
air conditioning if you're gonna [ __ ]
turn it off listen I'm talking about
that dentist that went out went over to
Zimbabwe you got to go grab a mic from
the from the closet there do you know
that story near this dentist from
Minnesota
he's a beet you know like he's one of
those big-game hunters you known him
he's one of those [ __ ] guys I'm gonna
shoot something that people think is
scary
and I could be the guy killed that [ __ ]
you know like it went up but he [ __ ]
put it in a chokehold take you didn't
you you went over and you shot it the
fact that you can go you can walk up and
kill an armed man a human being with a
gun you could [ __ ] kill you could you
could do it if he knew you were coming
you have a gun he has a gun you could do
that so now you going up to a lion the
thing doesn't have a gun so I mean how
[ __ ] difficult is that actually they
shot it with a crossbow but the reason
why they shot with a crossbow is because
they were trying to disguise doesn't he
have he's gone big-game hunting before
right like he's done it a lot
well here's the thing that I what I saw
some weirdly alarmist headline being
like you know he's like a serial killer
of animals and like the way they were
putting it was like you know this is
what he does all the time I don't know
he's one of those guys he thought he
doesn't seem like he kills to eat it
yeah that's just for support yeah he's
one of those guys to be like gay you
ever hear of an alligator [ __ ] shot
one in their head was he put it up in
his study or something he's one of those
guys so what about him he's fled right
like he went over to the Zimbabwean
where like a crossbow and he [ __ ]
went into some what wildlife sanctuary
allegedly this lion was friendly with
people I love that [ __ ] so that's all
the lion Cecil or whatever it was it's
yeah it's friendly until it isn't for
the one day you'd do something that
reminds us it you know but something
from its childhood and it [ __ ] bites
your head off but it's what is supposed
to toe it's a line yeah kill [ __ ] yeah
of course so you want any [ __ ] killed
it decapitated its skin the [ __ ]
thing okay what's the head yeah first of
all how do you get the head back I don't
know I don't want to know that you got
to go Jim Begg gonna drain it out they
probably do it they're like oh no you
know what he did he product taxidermy
well you probably like takes the [ __ ]
just the skin from the head you bring
that back and then you just you have
somebody like make a like a lion skull
and then you put it over there cuz no
one's gonna connote the skull isn't in
there right this is the kind of [ __ ]
this is like no idea let me ask you this
near because you're into American greed
this guy had dentists he paid 50
ran to do that mm-hmm now he's gone
underground they're going by his house
he has a mansion this guy's a dentist he
has a mansion and he's going all these
expensive [ __ ] you know going around
killing all these how does a dentist
have all that [ __ ] money
is he like a hoity-toity fancy dentist
that like doesn't take any insurance and
it's all like self-pay and it's I worked
in a dental office nobody was going on a
safari
even I just look at him forget about -
you just want a safari how much money
that is forget about you gotta go over
there and then sneak back later kill a
lion
what's your the [ __ ] thing and sneak
it back yeah I don't know he sounds very
sketchy though that's agreed as well
doing the themes of American green later
oh by the way so do you hope that the
United States extradite so this dentist
back to Zimbabwe do you feel like he
should do ten years in prison in a
hardcore prison I'm gonna give that he's
gonna get what Riggs
I think I think he should be fined
probably a lot like a lot don't [ __ ]
that I think he should be taken back at
some point you got to put a value on
animals lives I agree
what's the way you're saying he should
go to jail I think he should I don't
think you should go to the hardcore one
right I think that he should go to the
jail be in protective custody and
through his ten years he should have to
fix everybody's teeth I think for free
he should work in an animal sanctuary
like cleaning up all like the [ __ ] and
everything that he can't have that
that's like having a pedophile work at a
kindergarten eventually he's gonna
[ __ ] kill some it was that's all I
mean there's not some law in place about
him going and killing that animal
because it shouldn't there already be so
no there is but he left your country he
left the country he's brought here so
now he's got to get the United States to
send one of their own out of the United
States we're not gonna send the guy
mm-hmm because that's one of our guys
he's got the bar code in the back of his
neck and he's not making us any [ __ ]
money if he stood by us I mean the
Illuminati guys you know what I mean
he's not paying any [ __ ] income tax
or any of that type of [ __ ] he's not
walking around you know saying what he's
supposed to be saying cuz he got it out
of his TV you need that zombie you need
that guy he's a big-game hunter that guy
he's gonna be on the side of those I
gotta be honest with you I totally
respect hunting I think it's the [ __ ] I
love animals too but I think if you go
out and you hunt and then you do it for
food or whatever or you're doing it to
learn how to do it I respect that go
shoot a [ __ ] deer there's a zillion
of them they're like mosquitoes but I'd
like to go out there and and you know
she was lying a leopard - Jay these
beautiful [ __ ] animals with ya dude
believe me if there was a bunch of [ __ ]
if it was herds of lions running along
the prairies I mean I that's what we
would have on his a fourth of July but
whatnot we [ __ ] killed all him I think
there's really something like I don't
what this guy does I don't lump all
hundred hunters in - did he go out on
his own was he like this road he hired
Dede I was gonna say he hired people
right so he had people who knew the
terrain
those guys are possible - guys are going
to trial and they're staring at ten
years oh they are oh yeah and being a
bottom I was gonna say I know he paid
somebody like an exorbitant amount of
money it's in order to do that he didn't
just go out there on his own yeah he's
incredibly stupid I'm above the people
who live there and this [ __ ] guy I
don't know he must have had the size of
that duffle bag that he must have put
the [ __ ] head and it's just a jello
that's what the whole how does the head
travel what do you do I don't know you
put it up his ass like those drug mules
internationally are you gonna are you
bringing any fruit or any like wildlife
or any playing plants
I got an elephant's bed my duffel bag do
you mind if I look in your bag sir yes I
do
you have any liquids in there no it's
all been drained and he's oh sure pop
you can do any of that but the [ __ ]
with the
I actually think there's something
[ __ ] wrong with you if you have to go
around and kill the most deadliest
animals to human beings like walking
around doing that [ __ ] I feel like that
was an old-school like Teddy Roosevelt
yeah I'm an insecure guy and like you
say that thing this like foreign land
like isn't that the whole thing it's
like you sort of take over the people
and the neighborhoods and like the
countries and then like kill all their
wildlife isn't it all about like I'm the
big man and I can disorder yeah I don't
know all nature as well as man I don't
know what it's about what I can tell the
only thing I'll give them problems was
is he used to crossbow you know that's
but of course but you know what had the
[ __ ] laser pointer and [ __ ] but like
I I just I thought America has bigger
problems than rich people shooting lions